what's up guys my name is jason silva
you guys might know me as the host of
brain games on national geographic
channel for five
seasons now we live in disruptive times
planet has been sidelined by a viral
pandemic
and everything is up for grabs we have
an opportunity to
reinvent how we live and reinvent how we
work now i believe the human condition
is defined
by our capacity to overcome any and all
limitations
and boundaries i'm passionate about
creativity and
ingenuity and imagination and we will
imagine near
ourselves out of this predicament these
disruptive times are calling
for massive reinvention and so it begs
the question
what is the future of work what is the
new normal
how do we live how do we play how do we
work
how do we stay connected while being
physically apart
what is the future of the online meeting
do we need offices in the future there
are all these
questions that are being asked and all
these
new answers that are being forged but
one thing that i know
is that from disruption comes massive
transformation
massive innovation massive illumination
and
while it may seem like the world is
under
a dark cloud this too shall pass and we
shall learn from this
so let's have the conversation let's ask
the difficult
questions let's explore technological
disruption in human ingenuity let's look
at the pace of accelerating change
let's examine what the future holds how
will health care
be transformed how will collaboration
across
distances be forged in new ways how will
remote work
transform what it means to be productive
these are wonderful questions to ask
and i'm looking forward to working with
you guys to find those
answers cheers guys